we did a show in Mexico and a cousin of
mine reached out said hey you know I'm
I'm here having uh dinner with your dad
and I'm like oh and you hadn't seen it
for how long 15 years wow uh 15 years
ago plus
um
he had a friend in La who brought him
out to the comedy magic club to see me
perform it was crazy because I'm
backstage and Richard the manager at the
club
comes up to me and he goes Gabe listen
there's a guy in the crowd and he's
telling people he's your dad I'm like
okay another one that wants money or
tickets right what does he want don't
give him a DVD that's back then so he
goes yeah the guy's being real he's
being very like insisting really I go
come on Richard how long you know me
yeah it's somebody's just being you know
an ass so after the show was over I was
outside doing a meet and greet and so
people were coming up to me and like hey
we signed this or sign you don't take
pictures and stuff like that and uh sure
[__] my manager at the time pat buckles
Pat buckles my manager yeah she comes up
to me she goes Gabe there's a guy in the
back claiming to be your dad he's
waiting in line to meet you and I'll
just be honest with you I the eyes
it's
trust me and I and I my heart dropped
and I still had to finish my meet and
greet and I'm like oh my God how he's
holding a DVD in the line you know I was
like what am I gonna write on the
freaking DVD hey how you been yeah yeah
so once you saw him did you know uh you
know what I told her to tell him look
right now it's not good he's working and
he understood that so we got his info
and we actually had dinner with him the
next night at the comedy magic club
Richard set it up for me we had a nice
little meeting we sat down and we just
you know and previous to that I didn't
see him since you were a child yes
wow
uh you know it was funny because he made
the joke that yeah because I made fun of
him being the guy in the Tapatio bottle
because he was a mariachi yeah you know
when I said Mom you got any pictures of
my dad yeah and my mom was like he looks
like that
wow so anyways I had all those
uncomfortable you know uh questions and
answers 15 years ago yeah and I just
lost touch with them and what was that
like that first meeting or that first
dinner it was it was a very conflicting
because I had always been upset but I
didn't know why I was upset everybody
made me feel like my dad not being there
automatically meant that you know if for
some reason he were to try to come back
into the picture not forget this dude he
was never there but yeah again I never
got a clean explanation from my mom it
was more so emotional and I'm not and
you're taught don't question your
parents back then you don't this is how
it is and that's it and you're like okay
yeah there was no back and forth so
everything my mom said you know I just
took it and uh it wasn't until I had a
chance to talk to my dad and work
through issues at that dinner and so and
keep in mind it was a little bit more
challenging because he only spoke
English and my Spanish was you know [__]
you know he always [__] status man he
only spoke Spanish and my Spanish was
still like you know it was if I could
order food but I couldn't I couldn't
have like a meaningful conversation
emotionally deep yeah so I had my
girlfriend with me who was very fluent
so she was very helpful in getting the
conversation going yeah yeah you know
helping out were some of those uh
questions answered do you think you know
what yes because I had so much hatred
for my dad but I didn't know why again
and so
knowing that you know now I I under I
see it differently because I see it
Through The Eyes of an Entertainer I see
now like wow okay all right I think
about my mom and my mom hooking up with
somebody that's that's uh an Entertainer
they're traveling they're working every
night they're on stage the attention the
back and forth and I'm like yeah I think
my mom might have you know
yeah yeah yeah
so uh I kind of just like you know what
um the past is the past I get it you
know I'm good thank you for sitting with
me thank you for explaining to me and
and we're good you know I was good yeah
I I didn't stay in touch with them
though because he was in fact a stranger
to me I'm just like you just yeah we
look the same and yeah you know if I
need a kidney [__] I'll call you you
know but yeah yeah yeah but did you see
like real similarities similarities like
his mannerisms or the way he spoke or
his Cadence you know what super
charismatic super charismatic you could
tell he carries himself it's almost
Regal the way he carries himself
interesting it's not he's not sloppy
he's very much like man and very much
like you know he just he's old school
the guy's 80 years old now wow and even
now when you talk to him he's again very
charismatic he knows how to take a table
and just start talking to everyone and
he's super engaging so I can see why my
mom was like you know she's at all
do they have other kids or no he wants
yes he had uh two daughters and I met
them in December so the the thing was my
cousin reached out and I says look uh
this is awkward for me you know I'm I'm
done with that chapter I didn't stay in
touch but then when I found out I had
two sisters I said you know what maybe
this is a chance you can see that
earlier in the conversation talking
about wanting a kid this was already
after that kid thing and the dog thing
and let me try to find something real to
attach myself to oh wow and so I invited
him to come out to the show in Mexico
City on the condition that he brought my
sisters and then I also have nieces so
it was like all these people that showed
up yeah so it was really really cool
they were super nice and the fact that I
approached them not them approaching me
made all the difference in the world
because it wasn't like like them because
I get a lot of people saying they're
family members and they just want money
yeah you know I'm in Iglesias I had one
cousin cousin who actually had Iglesias
tattooed on his arm right here yeah hold
it up like a like look we're related
same name I'm like come on bro yeah
and then so they came backstage so also
uh no we actually sat down and had a
nice dinner and you know we talked and I
told him I go look I go
um
I feel like I'm a lot more mature and I
feel like we can have a real
conversation now versus back then where
it was all emotional and uh it was it
was very very cool it was very very
friendly it was very positive there was
no arguing there was no like you know
all the what the [__] I'm sorry I don't
mean to do it like men see it yeah all
the what the hell's yeah uh we're
already gone by that point it was it was
just nice to connect a lot of sweet
[__] thing and and so we hung out had
multiple dinners while I was there in
town they came to the show and so it was
it was nice um I have not stayed in
touch and I think that's out of fear
because I don't know you know the guy's
now 80. uh my sisters have their own
lives yeah but I I just don't know
because there's so much going on in my
life where I feel like so many people
were in we were close and now they're on
the outside and I'm like
am I good or bad in their lives you know
yeah it's a complex situation dude you
know and um but it's still beautiful man
you know
I'm so happy for you in that way you
know make because it's like you know I
I wouldn't I I wouldn't want to know and
I wouldn't want to know those things as
well you know what I mean and it I mean
for me it's like
I don't know I just I got goosebumps we
were talking about it man it's [__]
amazing dude yeah so all those uh you
know you do it in Spanish in Mexico City
are you English no I perform in in
English uh I can speak Spanish but it's
I feel like you lose a lot in the
translation and I have attempted to do
shows like I work with a guy named
Franco escamilla who's huge in Latin
America and even here when he does his
shows um I think I met him he probably
did because he hung up there was a guy
he's